До місцевих виборів в Україні ще три місяці,
запекла боротьба за крісло мера Києва вже набирає обертів.
Серед охочих очолювати столицю наступні п’ять років -
депутати, бізнесмени, шоумени, колишні мери великих і малих міст.
Нині вони активно завойовують симпатії киян.
У хід пішов вже традиційний для України інструмент
політичного протистояння – відеоролики у соцмережах.
Оновлюємо центр міста, старий Київ
і робимо його привабливим як для мешканців міста, так і для гостей, які приїжджають.
Тобто зміни ідуть. І вдень, і вночі ми працюємо і змінюємо Київ на краще.
Займемося добробутом, боротьбою з бідністю
і запросимо для цього людей, які це можуть.
Чи не найбільшою інтригою майбутньої виборчої кампанії в столиці
стала особа кандидата в мери від "Слуги народу".
Навесні найімовірнішими претендентами на мерське крісло називали
Олександра Ткаченка, Віктора Ляшка, Миколу Тищенка та Олександра Дубінського.
Однак пандемія коронавірусу і численні скандали за участі деяких депутатів
змусили "слуг народу" шукати альтернативу.
На внутрішньопартійних "праймеріз" перемогу здобула депутатка Ірина Верещук.
Сьогодні всі три, це максимум, бали отримала Ірина Верещук,
яка буде найкращим, найрозумнішим,
я в цьому впевнений, тому що ми бачили різних кандидатів,
найрозумнішим, найсимпатичнішим кандидатом.
Шукали нестандартний варіант,
кандидата-джокера, неочікуваного для Кличка кандидата
і вирішили зіграти на гендерному контрасті.
Кандидат-жінка і проти боксера Кличка,
і проти всіх інших.
Тому що на сьогодні
всі відомі кандидати в мери Києва - чоловіки
і поки що єдина жінка.
От я думаю, це можливо був останній, можливо вирішальний аргумент,
чому саме Ірина Верещук.
Ірина Верещук  пройшла до парламенту за партійними списками "Слуги народу".
Депутатка має досвід у самоврядуванні.
5 років була мером невеликого містечка Рава-Руська на Львівщині.
На думку Верещук, цього досвіду вистачить і для успішного управління столицею.
Жодного пункту своєї майбутньої виборчої програми кандидатка не називає,
лиш зазначає, що вона буде нелінійною і здивує конкурентів.
Наразі ж Верещук планує вразити киян красномовством
і вже викликала Віталія Кличка на словесну дуель.
Я не знаю, чому на стадіоні, можливо ми виберемо другу локацію,
але я уже вчора запросила пана Кличка.
Я знаю, що він такий чемпіон, що він спортсмен.
Ну і він мужчина.
Він не може відмовитися від дебатів з конкурентами,
а я вважаю, що я йому конкурент і маю на це підстави.
Політолог Володимир Фесенко вважає виклик на дебати нічим іншим,
як першим ходом "Слуги народу" на шахівниці мерських перегонів.
Я так розумію, це свідомий хід, знову ж таки, не стандартний.
Що називається загнати Віталія в глухий кут.
Якщо він погоджується, то ці дебати, як здавалося б, можуть бути на користь Ірини.
Ще й тому, що ще з часів Юлії Тимошенко, її піку популярності
всі політтехнологи знають, коли йдуть політичні дебати чоловіка і жінка,
навіть підсвідомоє емоційне співчуття на користь жінки.
Така перевага, це теж хочуть використати.
А якщо відмовляється Віталій від дебатів, то значить
боягуз, не хоче, боїться і тому подібне...
Так що отакі ігри – це вже от реальний початок виборчої кампанії.
На старті виборчих перегонів Віталій Кличко є беззаперечним лідером.
Результати останніх соціологічних опитувань свідчать:
якби вибори міського голови відбулися найближчим часом,
за чинного мера проголосували б 36% усіх опитаних або 44% тих,
хто готовий взяти участь у виборах і вже визначився з кандидатом.
На думку експертів, однією із причин високого рейтингу Кличка
є вдала комунікації з киянами під час карантину та покращення міської інфраструктури.
Моє завдання - робити все для того, щоб вводити в експлуатацію нові об’єкти
того, щоб вони були надійними,
безпечними сучасними і швидко відкривалися.
Робимо все для цього.
Електорат Віталія Кличка, судячи з усього, цінує його здобутки останніх 5 років
і саме тому готовий проголосувати за ще один термін для нинішнього мера.
Я бачу, що Київ змінюється на краще.
Можливо не все ідеально, але дуже великий розвиток для Києва є,
тому як можна вибрати іншого кандидата, навіть не уявляю. Тільки Кличко.
Я думаю, що коней не мають міняти.
Дати ще раз Кличку термін для того, щоб він міг зробити те, що він хотів.
Але треба йому допомогти.
Я думаю, що пройдуть вибори, він залишиться,
але прийде до Київради нова команда.
Я думаю, що вони йому допоможуть зробити.
Ви знаєте, вже настільки зневірилися.
Люди все обіцяють, обіцяють, тільки б дорватися до влади.
Потім як стають, нічого не роблять.
Тому цей хоч щось робить. Дороги ремонтує, парки поробив.
Ще до рішення "Слуги народу" висунути на мерські перегони у Києві
Ірину Верещук основним супротивником Віталія Кличка,
за даними соцопитувань, був бізнесмен і телеведучий Андрій Пальчевський.
Йому симпатизують близько 10% респондентів.
Хоча сам Пальчевський ще не підтвердив своєї участі в виборах мера,
його обличчя дедалі частіше з’являється на бігбордах та в ефірі телеканалів.
Він грає на настроях тих виборців, які раніше голосували за Партію регіонів
чи за комуністів голосували.
Їх в Києві десь до 20%.
Чи зможе він проявитися якнайскравіше в цьому плані,
тоді можливо, що саме він вийде в другий тур.
А те, що буде в другому турі, ніхто зараз не може сказати,
тому що головна мета Кличка зараз – це не доводити до другого туру.
Скласти конкуренцію чи принаймні відібрати частину електорату Віталія Кличка
можуть кандидати від "Голосу" та "Європейської солідарності".
Експерти нагадують, що паралельно обирається Київрада,
і для партій баталії за крісла у ній будуть не менше принциповими.
Сама фракція, будь-яка фракція в Київраді
– це серйозний ресурс в боротьбі.
Знову ж таки, не обов’язково вигравати мерську кампанію.
Можна програти її, чи виграти, як у випадку Кличка.
Він виграє, стає мером.
Але перше, у слуг народу є чудова можливість проголосувати таки закон
про столицю, де розділити ці посади,
що обнуляє певною мірою значимість посади мера.
А друге – це не сформувати більшість у Київраді.
І тоді це постійна боротьба і теж величезні проблеми.
У "Слузі народу" не приховують – на міських виборах очікують повторити
минулорічний успіх президентських і парламентських перегонів.
Подивіться на вибори президента, все було теж відомо.
А потім на вибори парламенту. Все теж було відомо.
Все було закладено, все було пораховано, гроші були виділені.
Схеми були готові, піраміди працювали,
Правда ж? Не будемо заперечувати очевидне. Все буде гаразд.
Ми зробили тоді і зробимо зараз.
На президентських перегонах за Володимира Зеленського проголосували 60% киян,
а його партію на парламентських виборах підтримали 36% виборців у Києві.
Однак на виборах мера кияни мають фаворита – Віталія Кличка.
Аби скласти йому гідну конкуренцію, інші кандидати повинні
за три наступні місяці стати своїми для жителів столиці
і запропонувати програму змін в Києві.
Політичні аналітики допускають, що нарощуючи власні рейтинги,
претенденти на крісло мера столиці водночас вдаватимуться до компроматів
і темних піар-технологій, аби збільшити антирейтинг Віталія Кличка.
Однак ці інструменти активно використають
ближче до дня виборів – 25 жовтня.